Guten Abend Herr Doktor.
Mein Name ist Usluogullare. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assisten der Arztätik.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Ich bin damit ein Verstand.
Aber natürlich, deswegen bin ich ja gekommen Herr Doktor.
Ja, danke schön.
Zuerst möchte ich einige personische Frage stellen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Julia.
Wie ist Ihre Vorname?
Mein Vorname ist Julia.
Mein Nachname ist Weingärtner.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Nachname bestabieren?
Weingärtner, Walter, Emil, Ida, Nordpol, Gustav, Ehe, mit Umlaut, Richard, Theodor, Nordpol, Emil, Richard.
Weingärtner.
Weingärtner, genau.
Mit 3 Punkten.
Frau Weingärtner, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 36 Jahre alt.
Was ist genau geworden?
3.8.86.
Wie groß sind Sie, Frau Weingärtner?
Ich bin 1,78 m.
Wie viel sind Sie?
Ich wiege 73 kg.
Was für Sie ist uns?
Herr Doktor, ich habe seit Wochen immer wieder krärende Unterbauchschmerzen.
Das wird mal besser.
Dann kommen Sie immer wieder.
Und jetzt, seit gestern, sind Sie ganz heftig.
Wie lange geht da, wenn Sie Schmerzattacken?
Also jetzt, seit gestern, anhalten.
Ich habe wirklich seit gestern Abend extreme Krämpfe und Unterbauchschmerzen.
Das wird nicht besser.
Wie Sie sehen, ich muss immer heulen.
Ich weiß nicht, was es ist.
Das kommt immer wieder.
Wo ist Ihr Schmerz?
Im unteren Bauch.
Unter dem Bauch.
Wie sieht das Schmerz aus?
Im unteren Bauch, mal nach rechts, mal nach links aus.
Aber in die Leisten.
Ich kann es nicht genau sagen.
Es ist mal rechts, mal nach links.
Es ist mehr auf der rechten Seite und in der Mitte.
Okay.
Wichtig ist, dass Sie Schmerzen auf einer Skala ein leichter sehen.
Ich starte entsprechend.
Also jetzt, seit gestern, würde ich sagen, bei 7, 8.
Ja, genau.
Haben Sie bemerkt, gibt es ein bestimmter Auslöser für diese Schmerzen?
Zum Beispiel nach dem Essen oder?
Das kam jetzt spontan.
Ich habe auch keinen Durchfall.
Der Stuhlgang ist normal.
Ich weiß es echt.
Sie haben einen Erwert, haben Sie keinen Durchfall?
Haben Sie Durchfall oder Verstoffung?
Nein.
Nein, der Stuhlgang ist normal.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, aber habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Übelkeit?
Manchmal habe ich eine leicht übelkeit.
Ganz wenig.
Haben Sie nicht Erbrechen?
Haben Sie nicht Erbrocken?
Erbrechen habe ich nicht.
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
Sie haben eine kramfartige Attacke erwähnt.
Oder kramfartige Schmerzen.
Ja.
Und sind die Schmerzen immer schirm geworden?
Ja, die fangen immer ganz leicht an.
Und werden dann in einem von wenigen Stunden,
werden die ganz heftig bestimmt werden.
Haben Sie schon diese Schmerzen erlebt?
Ja, ich sage ja, ich habe das seit einigen Monaten schon.
Aber so schlimm wie jetzt waren sie noch nie.
Einige Monaten, aber ja.
Jetzt ist ganz heftig.
War sie dafür beim Arzt?
Ja, ich war beim Hausarzt.
Der hat mich dann zu meiner Frauenärztin geschickt.
Aber bisher kam nichts raus.
Ja.
Sind Ihre Masterclasses regelmäßig?
Ja, da habe ich bisher eigentlich keine Probleme.
Sind Sie sicher, dass derzeit haben Sie nicht Schwangerschaft?
Nein, ich bin nicht schwanger.
Nein, ich wohne im Moment alleine.
Ich habe keinen Partner.
Haben Sie beim Wasserlasten Probleme?
Nein, ich habe vor einer Woche mal ein leichtes Brennen gehabt.
Aber das ist wieder weg.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Also der Appetit ist gut.
Da habe ich keine Probleme.
Ich habe Hunger, ich kann essen.
Aber jetzt, wenn die Schmerzen da sind,
dann habe ich Angst zu essen.
Ich denke, dass die Schmerzen dann schlimmer werden.
Aber eigentlich ist es damit nicht so.
Ja, Sie sollen nicht am schlimmsten denken, wie gucken.
Und haben Sie in der Zeit, derzeit Appetit zu genommen?
Nein, das Gewicht ist immer gleich geblieben.
Haben Sie Nachschweiß?
Nein, ich kann sehr gut schlafen.
Da habe ich jetzt kein Problem.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein, schwindelig ist mir auch nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Husten, Brustschmerzen,
oder irgendein andere Körper?
Die Luft und die Lunge ist eigentlich in Ordnung.
Da habe ich eigentlich kein Problem.
Okay, gut.
Haben Sie für die Krampungen oder krönschen Krankheiten?
Man sich jetzt nicht.
Ich habe eine leichte Schilddrüsen-Unterfunktion.
Und nehme deswegen auch Schilddrüsen-Tabletten.
Da bin ich immer in der Kontrolle.
Und mein Hausarzt sagt, das ist alles in Ordnung bisher.
Haben Sie andere Krankheiten?
Nein, nein.
Wie viele Milligramm Nehmen Sie?
75.
Erlteroxen, 75.
Nehmen Sie morgen für das Frisch?
Ja, genau.
Und, wo sind Sie schon operiert?
Ich habe mal als Kind Mandeln bei mir rausoperiert worden.
Woher habe ich noch keine Operation bisher?
Keine Operation.
Und keine andere Krankheiten?
Ja.
Und haben Sie Allergie?
Ich habe eine Polyne Allergie.
Und ich bin allergisch gegen Erdnüsse.
Wie reagieren Sie auf dieser Allergie?
Ich bekomme Hautausschlag.
Und dann ist auch Luftnot dabei.
Ein Juckreiz am ganzen Körper fängt dann an.
Okay, ich habe verstanden.
Haben Sie Unverträglichkeit gegen Lebensmittel?
Nein, bisher habe ich eigentlich alles sehr gut vertragen.
Und rufen Sie?
Nein.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Eigentlich nicht, aber ab und zu mal, wenn ein Fest oder eine Feier ist,
dann trinke ich mal ein Glas Wein, aber ansonsten nicht.
Und das ist eine routine Frage.
Haben Sie schon Drogen probiert?
Drogen? Ach so, am Gott, das hören Sie.
Nein, nein, nein.
Eine routine Frage, nicht per se.
Okay, gut.
Und waren Sie schon in Ausland?
Ja, immer wieder mal.
Wir waren verreist in verschiedenen Ländern.
Aber in der letzter Zeit waren Sie?
Oh, ne, seit einem Jahr jetzt nicht.
Wurden Sie schon gegen Corona vorstandig geimpft?
Ja, ich bin auch schon geboost hat, ja.
Und sind Ihre Eltern am Leben?
Ja, sie leben noch.
Und haben Sie kranische Krankheiten, wie ich wissen sollte,
zum Beispiel Brutopdruck, Brutzuckerkrankheit?
Also mein Vater hat Runddruck, das stimmt,
wenn ich auch Medikamente habe, weil ich weiß nicht, wie Sie heißen.
Ein Problem, Mutter?
Meine Mutter hatte mal, wo ein, zwei Jahren,
wo so einen fraglichen Diabetes, aber die haben eine Idee gemacht
und jetzt geht es sehr gut, also sie nehmen auch keine Medikamente.
Sehr gut.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe noch eine Schwestern, ja.
Ist sie gesund?
Sie ist gesund, sie ist topfit, sie ist eine Sportlerin, ja.
Ja, sehr gut.
Und Sie haben erwähnt, Sie sind nicht verheiratet,
ledig und leben alleine.
Ja.
Und Sie sind nicht verheiratet?
Nein, ich bin da nicht.
Und was ist Ihr Problem?
Ich bin Anwälte.
Anwälte?
Anwälte, ja.
Sie haben gesagt, also Ihre messielles Geschwister ist regelmäherd,
aber haben Sie Schmerzen während der messielles Geschwister?
Ja, manchmal, aber natürlich habe ich eigentlich relativ gut im Griff.
Da nehme ich manchmal Paracetamol, wenn es nötig ist,
aber ansonsten habe ich da keine Probleme.
Und haben Sie in der Arbeit sehr stressig oder im Leben?
Ja, das ist natürlich schon sehr stressig,
aber es ist jetzt nicht mehr oder weniger als sonst.
Ich denke nicht, dass die Probleme zwischen der Arbeit kommen.
Ich arbeite sehr gerne.
Mir macht die Arbeit Spaß.
Aber ich fühle das jetzt nicht als großen Stress.
Ja, Frau Weinjagd.
Ich habe für mich alle wichtigen Fragen gestattet.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder Fragen?
Vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit, Doktor.
Was denken Sie, ist es richtig?
Ja.
Was wollen Sie jetzt noch tun?
Ja, Sie haben es nicht so schwer gemacht.
Aber jetzt kann ich nicht mehr sagen,
erst muss ich für Parasiten untersuchen
und einige Diagnostische untersuchen durchgehen.
Danach könnte ich dazu mehr sagen.
Sie haben eine Darmsündung.
Das ist eine Darmsündung.
Das ist jetzt auch eine Darmsündung.
Vielleicht ein bisschen.
Das ist das erste Thema, das ich rüber siehe.
Okay.
Das ist das erste Thema.
Aber wenn du diesen Moment nicht zu schmerzen,
Ja, im Moment ist es schlimmer.
Also wenn du einen Schmerzmedikament haben.
Ich würde mich so körperlich unterzulachen, sofort machen, dann kann ich natürlich Schmerz-Tablete geben.
Aber jetzt kann ich nicht geben, weil ich bestimmte Diagnose nicht schütterle.
Dann würde ich Sie bitte beeilen, weil die Schmerzen sind schon sehr stark. Vielen Dank.
Ja, gerne. Bitte.
Danke schön, Herr Doktor. Ja, gut. Das war sehr gut, Herr Doktor. Wunderbar.
Gut, wollen Sie gleich die Übergabe an den Oberarzt machen?
Oder an den Kollegen haben Fragen?
Das machen wir vielleicht am Schluss, wenn Sie ihn recht sind, oder?
Oder haben die Kollegen direkt eine Frage im Moment zu dieser Anamnese?
Und die Kolleginnen?
Haben wir etwas vergessen oder hat Herr Doktor etwas vergessen?
Mhm, natürlich.
Haben Sie Blähungen?
Blähungen? Ja, Blähungen.
Ja, ich habe schon das Gefühl, dass der Bauch etwas aufgedunsen ist oder aufgebläht ist.
Und ich merke auch, die Winde gehen etwas vermehrt ab. Das stimmt.
Jetzt sind Sie letzte seit Ihr Restaurant oder aus Lebensbetrachten?
Nein, also ich koche meistens selber und ich achte darauf, dass es auch immer gesund ist und dass ich immer frische Nahrungsmittel und Gemüse habe.
Also ich esse überwiegend zu Hause.
Okay, dann machen wir das, Doktor.
Ja, Herr Oberarzt, haben Sie seit ich möchte Ihnen eine Patientin vorstellen.
Ja, bitte gerne, freut mich sehr. Bitte schon.
Ja, Frau Julia Weingartner ist eine 36-jährige Patientin.
Die Patientin stellt sich bei uns wegen seit einer Woche aufgetretener, bester, aufgetretener Kraftartiger und Zunehmender Unterbauchschmerzen vor.
Und die Schmerzen, Strahlen, Ganzen Unterbauch und auch Rechte Seite aus, in die Rechte Seite aus.
Die Patientin hat eine Verstärkung, die Verstärkung, die Verneidung der Verneidung der Verstärkung der Patientin.
Und die Patientin klappt über nur weniger Übelkeit.
Ja, weniger Übelkeit.
Und die Patientin habe diese Schmerzen, wie leicht er vor einem Monat erlebt.
Und sie war bei dieser Hausarzt gewesen und auch die Necologen gewesen, aber alles war unauffällig und kein Befund.
Kein Befund. Und die Patientin hat gut Appetit.
Und die vegetative Anamnese sei unauffällig.
Und die Patientin habe ihre Messersignis auch regelmäßig und sie sei nicht schwanger.
Sein nicht schwanger oder sie habe keine Schwangerschaft.
Und die Patientin leidet an Hypothyroise und sie nimmt regelmäßig etwa 75 Milligramm jeden Tag.
Nicht Milligramm, Mikrogramm.
Und sie wurde die Patientin sei wegen, die Patientin wurde dektomiert.
Ja, natürlich.
Ah, okay.
Sie ist anwärtsin.
Ja, sie ist nicht viel stressig in der Arbeit.
Nicht viel stressig bei der Arbeit.
Ja, bei der Arbeit.
Und auf dieser amnestischen Angabe,
die Leute am Herstin,
Qualitis,
ein Monat, Qualitis,
die deuten auf eine Qualitis, okay.
Qualitis, ja Qualitis hin.
Welche Art auch immer.
Qualitis hin, Artiferenzialdiagnosen,
Common Appendicitis,
und also Systitis,
Systitis, ja un,
Systitis und
oder
Gast...
Gastroenthe...
Irritable Column
Column ist irritable
im Betracht
Column is irritable natürlich
Was kann der Grund ist trotzdem sein
wenn es unauffällig war aber vielleicht
doch noch, ja
Atnixitis vielleicht
Atnixitis ja, es kann sein
oder
ja, eistokruttur
Genau, eine Rucur
eistokruttur
natürlich
Woran muss man vielleicht eine Differenzialdiagnose
noch?
Äh...
Unterwachschmerzen
oder
Traumverartige Unterwachschmerzen
mit Ausstrahlingen in der Leiste
Was kann das noch sein
Rechte Seite
Es kommt von den Niere, geht runter
Rheulitis
Vielleicht hat sie doch sein
Rheulitis ja
Genau, gynecologisch
und dem Metriosis
auch im Betracht
natürlich
Ich habe aber nicht Pankratis
keine Vorerkrankungen
andere
Erkrankungen oder Medikamenten
hat sie jetzt nicht
nicht alkohol, viel alkohol
Reialtrosion
kann natürlich auch sein
Also jegliche
gynecologische
Mühlen zeigen
Aber ich habe Besonderst
Gefrack
gynecologisch annamen
Sie hat mir gesagt
restliche Monat hat sie
gynecologisch besucht
und weitere Abklärung
meiner Verdachtdiagnose
empfehle ich
die folgende Diagnostische Masnamen
körperliche Übersicht
Laborabde
Ersindeparamat
Parameter
Brutbild
Leber Funktion
Nierenfunktion
Euro-Status
Euro-Kultur
Auch natürlich muss ich die Sonografie durchführen.
Und natürlich auch die Akdomen-Aufnahme.
Und nochmal eine Vorstellung bei den Gynäkologen.
Das war gut.
Sie haben an viele Differenzialdiagnosen gedacht.
Sie haben auch sehr gute Fragen gestellt.
Und von daher denke ich, war das in Ordnung.
Sie machen das sehr gut.
Was ist Ihre Prüfung?
17. Februar.
Das war aber auch sehr gut.
Ich glaube schon, dass es klappt.
Das hört sich schon mal ganz gut an.
Inschallah.
Haben die anderen Kolleginnen noch Fragen?
Das ist wirklich eine Patientin.
Wir können die Aufnahme stoppen.
Sie hat einen MRT vom Bauch bekommen.
Keine Indokulose, keine Variationen.
Keine gynecologische Erkrankungen.
Ich habe auch in Richtung Darm empfohlen, dass man Abführmittel gibt.
Dass man trotzdem etwas besseres Stuhlgang bekommt.
Und eine Magent- und Darmspiegelung.
Ob sie eine chronisch entzündliche Darmerkrankung hat.
Wie Kulitisulzarosa.
Und dann muss man gucken.
Natürlich.
Aber können wir Kolon irritabel nicht denken?
Ich glaube, das ist der erste Attacke.
Sie hat nicht viel Stress.
Und nicht durch Fall.
Das ist richtig.
Kolon irritabel, also das Reizdam-Syndrom.
Kann sich sehr unterschiedlich projizieren.
Aber durch Merk haben, das kann auch.
Meistens ist es ein Wechsel zwischen Durchfall und Bestopfung.
Natürlich auch, wenn es passiert, noch mehr vorhanden.
Aber trotzdem muss man auch daran denken.
Sehr gut.
Was sind Sie für ein Facharzt, Doktor?
Sie sind für ein Facharzt.
Ich bin.
Welche Fachrichtung?
Wir haben in der Geschichte von, ich bin Endocrinologin.
Endocrinologin.
Ich hatte es nicht mehr ganz.
Mein Name ist Alper hier.
Wir haben telefoniert.
Ich bin eine große Endocrinologie.
Endocrinologie.
Okay, gut.
Ich glaube, die anderen haben keine Fragen.
Dann bedanke ich mich ganz herzlich.
Ich bedanke mich auch.
Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg, Doktor.
Sie sagen mir Bescheid, wenn Sie bestanden haben.
Immer.
Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg, Doktor.